Hey everybody, it's Mike. Good morning.
Thanks for coming out this Thursday. You
know, it's uh
I'm here in Chicago and it's finally got
some rain. It's been uh
uh weather's been all over the place
except rain. So, it's uh kind of a
gloomy day out there, but you know, it's
it's nice to uh get in front of you guys
again. You know, it's been a while since
I've done any uh I haven't posted any
videos on YouTube in a while
cuz we've been working so hard on this
uh Order Flows Toolbox and I think it's
going to
you know, help a lot of traders out
there that, you know, want to add order
flow
to their trading, but at the same time,
you know, don't necessarily want to use
an order flow chart. So, let me just
make sure couple of last second checks.
Make sure my mic is on. It looks like
it's on. You can see my screen. That's
good. Good morning uh Luciano and uh
good morning Elad. You know, it's
it's always exciting when
you sort of I say discover something
new, but um you know, this is something
that in the back of my mind, you know,
we've been working on for quite a while
and I really had to you know, sort of
push my programmer to get this done
because
you know, I said
yeah,
I said, you know, really what we want to
do is we want to help traders, right?
And you know, the best way to do it is
is to put a tool together that's going
to help them understand the order flow a
lot better. So, let's just sort of jump
in here and and get started.
Um hang on here. Of course, now my
screen's not working.
There we go.
Um
Oops, there we go.
So, again, you know, just a brief
disclaimer, you know, we're all adults,
you know, trading does involve risk and
you know, don't trade with money you
can't afford to lose.
So,
you know, when it comes to order flow,
it feels like you're drowning in an a
sea of information, right? You look at a
footprint chart and it can be
overwhelming, especially for new
traders. You know, for experienced
traders, it it's easy peasy, but again,
not everybody is
at that level and you know, coming to
um, you know, order flow for the first
time, I I know myself, you know, I was
like, what the heck is this?
And you know, but once I sat down and
understood it, then it made a lot of
sense, but you know, there there's right
brain people, there's left brain people
and you know, people comprehend things a
lot easier than than others and I and I
understand that and respect that. That's
why, you know, I think the order flows
toolbox is going to, you know, help a
lot of traders because you know, there
is frustration in sifting through
endless footprint charts, you know,
people go out and I can't make sense of
the
footprints. So, I'll go to a heat map
and they end up back at at a bar chart.
Um, and and worst of all is, you know,
you have this information overload and
you end up missing opportunities and
unclear signals. So, really what you
need is a tool that's going to not only
simplify that chaos, but also enhance
your trading style, giving you that edge
over the competition. You'll basically
over um, the edge over the person
sitting on the other side of the world
that's also trading in the opposite
direction.
So, just you know, most of you know who
I am, but just really brief, uh, you
know, my name is Michael Valtos and you
know, I have started on the CME trading
floor when there was a floor. Uh,
eventually I left the trading floor when
electronic trading started. Um,
I've worked for Dean Witter, EDF Man,
Commerzbank, Cargill and JP Morgan
before starting orderflows.com about a
decade ago. Okay? So,
let's just uh, sort of just jump into
the meat and bones here. I don't need to
fluffy up with some stories and
things cuz
really what you want to see is, you
know, can this help me in my trading?
So, you know, when you look at a
footprint chart for a lot of traders,
you know, this you they use my software,
the Order Flows Trader software. I think
it
I know it's helped a lot of traders, but
I think it's, you know, the best
footprint chart out there in terms of,
you know, helping you analyze the data,
right? We have all sorts of tools that
really um, you know, help a trader hone
in on what they want to look for
because, you know, there's certain parts
of order flow that are great for
identifying reversals. There's other
parts of order flow that are great for,
um, identifying momentum.
Okay?
And if you don't know what to look for,
th- then looking at a footprint chart is
really useless. It's not like you're
going to just put a footprint chart on
your screen and all of a sudden it's
going to magically come to you, right?
You have to learn what
it means in terms of, you know, this
volume coming in here or that volume
coming in there, you know,
is why is this more important than the
other? And again, you know, for a lot of
traders, I see a comment in there
from Vikram saying, yeah, order flow is
very confusing and I need clarity. So,
in the past, right? If you're looking at
a footprint chart, now, you know, in the
past, it was just a simple,
you know, volume on the bid, volume on
the offer, and the
point of control, the volume point of
control, right? And the Order Flows
Trader, you know, we've added a lot of
the tools that I use in my own trading,
um, such as, you know, you know,
obviously, imbalances is a common thing,
but things like thin prints,
um, imbalance reversals, you know,
multiple imbalances, um, even some delta
tools, and
there are certain alignments, so to
speak, of,
you know, when you have a bar that has,
you know, a thin print or in two
imbalances and inverse
uh, sorry, Uh, says imbalance volume, it
should be, uh, inverse volume imbalance.
In the bar,
you know, it it can give some great
signals, okay? But, the problem was, you
know, in the past, you got to, you know,
before Orderflows Trader came along, you
had to actually look at the footprint
and say, "Okay, yeah, I got a thin print
coming in there. Yeah, I've got two
buying imbalance. Yes, I've got an
inverse
volume imbalance coming in in the bar."
And,
you know, so you really had to be locked
and loaded on your chart, looking at
your chart, to
identify those situations
when they occur. You know, cuz there's
going to be times where you have just
one of the three, right? Maybe you just
got the thin print with, um, two
imbalances, but you don't have the
inverse volume imbalance, right? Or or
maybe you have, um,
you know,
the thin print
and, you know, just an inverse volume
imbalance, right? You don't necessarily
always have the combination that you're
looking for. So, what I asked my
programmer to do
is, "Hey, you know what? Why don't we
make a tool, right? Cuz in the past,
right, you'd have to go in and, you
know, you'd click the things you want to
see with the Orderflows Trader that
you'd want to highlight on your chart.
Why don't we make a tool where
it would just highlight when there is,
um, a thin print, when there is a volume
imbalance, um, when there is an inverse
volume imbalance, and just show that to
me on the chart."
Right? And, you know, another step that
we took is
being able to filter it for momentum or
for swing highs or swing lows, okay?
Because, again, you know, not every
Orderflow tool that we've developed
is meant to be used for
the same purpose, it meaning, you know,
there's some that are better for
reversals, such as an the reversal, it's
got reversal in its name. That is
something you'd be looking for
um
you know, as a potential reversal. So,
that's something you want to use with a
swing high or swing low, not necessarily
um with momentum. Right? And you know,
and if a market is moving, you know, a a
signal like an open point of control
is something that you'd want to use in
momentum, okay? Cuz look at this, right?
This is the same setting, inverse volume
balance, thin prints volume imbalance as
this one, but you know, there's some bad
trades in there, right? Well, why?
Because um some of these aren't
necessarily meant to be
reversals. So, if you can filter that
out and say, "Hey, you know what? I want
to use the momentum
tools when there's momentum in the
market." So, you see like that losing
trade that was there.
I've added momentum.
Right? Whoops.
It's gone now. Just as this one, right?
This is looks like it's a potential
reversal, but it's really not.
Right? Cuz once you add in the reversal
filter, then it's gone because you know,
these
you know, thin prints is something
that's that's really meant to be used in
momentum.
So, what are the tools that are in and
I'm going to go through it, you know,
I'm going to show you I'm going to pull
up NinjaTrader. We're going to go
through, but this is the list of the
um tools, the order flow indicators that
we've added into the order flows
toolbox. Yeah, and I'll grant it in
swing filter
is
not based on order flow per se, but
everything else is, you know, the max
delta thresholds, um resting liquidity,
prominent point of controls, POC waves,
slingshot the ratios, the sequencing, um
you know, imbalance reversals, balance
reloads, sweeps, weakness, momentum,
strength,
um exhaustion prints, delta tails,
divergence, breakouts, etc. So, it's
pretty robust, you know, you're The only
thing that limits you is is your
Well, I I don't want to use the word
imagination, but you know, your your
thought process of what you like to look
for in the order flow. And I I've
created this little cheat sheet
and you know, to help traders
understand, you know, which tool
you know, is is really meant for
reversal, which one's meant for
momentum, confirmation, support or
resistance. Now, you know, obviously
some could be everything. Some really
are just meant for
And some, you know, can be used for you
know, two or three. Okay? So, you know,
just bear that in mind because
um
I did get this email yesterday
um from one of our
early users
and he had both the swing filter and
momentum. All right, that's why I have
this spreadsheet which is going out.
Cuz you can't Because remember, right?
If you have a swing filter, right?
You're looking for a swing high or swing
low
for a reversal. All right? So, if you're
And then if you're trying to find
something that's got momentum behind it,
well,
it's just not going to work cuz they
they work opposite each other. And but
this should help a lot of traders out.
Um you know, like if you're looking at
something like the POC wave,
really you know, what what you want to
use it for. Prominent point of control
can be used in a lot of different uh
things.
You know, the retail suck.
Now, the primary use I have the X here
so you can see you know, how I
um
predominantly use them in the indi- um
in
seeing them in the order flow, right? I
would look for
reversals.
Sorry. I'll drink some water.
So, for example, if I'm looking at a
retail suck, ideally I want to use that
with a swing filter
because that would be a reversal sign.
Whereas if it's a tool that uses
momentum,
um you know, like for example, extreme
delta threshold or delta volume
threshold, that's something that I would
use it with the momentum
filter, okay? So, that that should help
help you guys out a bit in sort of
putting in together your own trading
strategies.
Now,
another thing that we've added onto this
is the multi-time frame chart
capabilities. So, it's going to allow
you to analyze different time frames or
chart types. So, say you're trading, you
know, a 1-minute chart,
but you want to be aware of,
you know, like what the example I said,
you want to see thin prints that held on
a 5-minute chart on your 1-minute chart,
you can. So, basically, you see higher
time frame order flow on your lower time
frame chart. And, you know, some people
like to look at stacked imbalances that
have held over, you know, 15 minutes,
you know, they they're
they don't happen that often during the
normal trading day, but
you know, they want to be alerted to it
if if something like that's holding cuz
they don't normally look at a 15-minute
chart. So, there's a lot of capabilities
that you can do.
So, I'm going to go to the charts here
in a second, but I'm going to go through
a couple questions. Um,
let me see here. So,
uh
where is it here?
Hey, there's a question is is this going
to be recorded? This is a live webinar,
um not a pre-recorded one.
And also, this will be recorded. I'll
send you the replay later.
Um, Vikram says, "Yeah, order flow is
confusing and I need clarity." Yeah, I
mean, I I understand that. Aaron, I did
see your email. I was actually I'm glad
you're here cuz I was going to answer
it, but since you're here, I can answer
that right now. He says, "Will the order
flow toolbox require the same resources
as order flow software?" My current data
download is not great, even though my
hardware
CPU, RAM, Wi-Fi are all good. Well, it
it runs on NinjaTrader, right? It's a
Ninja Trader add-on.
Um
I don't know where you're getting your
data from.
But, you know, I I've
got data coming in. My mine is a CQG CQG
feed as well. I know you mentioned that
yours was.
Um
but it's coming from Ninja Trader
Brokerage directly. I don't have any
issues with it.
So, I I don't I'm not sure where your
your data exactly is is coming from
that's that's causing that problem.
Um
And
um
all my users that trade through Ninja
Trader Brokerage, they also using the
same data feed, I believe. Uh as well.
Um
So, and then they don't really report
any issues.
Um cuz if you get a data feed from like
Kinetic, that would be a data feed, not
a not a trading feed. I mean, you could
uh get a data feed from Kinetic or IQ
feed
uh through Ninja Trader, but you still
got to enter your trades through a uh
connect a connection.
That's a trading connection. Um
Okay, Juan's it's uh it's a holiday in
your country. Yeah, that's uh
that's a holiday for me. My kids started
school yesterday. Finally, they're out
of the house. Um yeah, I'll look for
your question there. You said I'll send
you the same question that I sent via
email.
But, um
yeah, Aaron, sorry to just get back to
that. You know, just
again, it's
Yeah, data
is I'm glad you sort of brought this up
because data is really
the data feed is a very important aspect
of trading cuz if you're slow, right?
You know the saying, you snooze, you
lose. If you if your data feed isn't
good,
yeah, it costs money, basically. You
know, money and
missed opportunities and and lost
trades and
executions. So, yeah, you want to make
sure you have a good uh
a good
connection. But again, you know, the
software runs on NinjaTrader
8 and you know, I've got a few
NinjaTrader 8s running. You know, I've
got my main trading system, a testing
system, a laptop. Um
and they're all fine, you know, as it
turn you know, they This one's an i9, my
other one's an i7. I think my laptop's
an i5. And
you know, with Kinetic it seems stable.
Um
Okay, Nabi asks
with NQ dancing up and down
how can momentum charts help? Well,
yeah, I'll I'll take a look at that in a
moment.
Um
will you share the cheat sheet?
Yeah, you know, I mean for
any user they'll they'll be sending it
out and and for users of Order Flow
Traders, I know I've been sort of
promising you that for the last week.
But um I'm going to be sending that out
later uh for Order Flow Traders users.
Um Jacob asks about uh
show
ES on an eight range or something. Let
me make a note here. Show NQ
momentum and eight range
ES, okay.
And Michael is saying you run uh
multiple indicators at the same time,
say one for reversals, one for Yep, you
can. You could uh I'll show you that.
Well,
let me just uh get my chart up here and
then
Okay.
Uh might be a little bit easier than
looking at a blank screen.
Uh
And I have to use Tradeovate platform.
Okay, then that case just get uh Kinetic
data feed.
Uh Luciano asks, I I sent an email about
this. Could you let me know if I should
drop the Delta Scalper? No, and use the
toolbox which I bought to spot trading
opportunities on different markets. Uh
Well, no, because actually the Delta
Scalper
the what goes into it you can't do with
um
the toolbox anyway, right? So, some of
the the the individual indicators that
we have out there
is
different is it's not tools that we've
already built into the Order Flows
Trader. So, it's not going to be in the
toolbox.
Okay?
Um sound alerts I believe there's sound
alerts in there.
Okay.
All right. Um
Would you advise automated trading using
these indicators? Yeah, you of course.
Um
Okay. All right, let's go uh let's
Anyway, let's I see there's a couple
other questions there. Markets are live
now.
Um
Does the the combined signals produce
plots that you can automate to trade?
Yeah, see. So,
this is What is this? Well, this is
ultra bonds. Um and this one's just a
simple one. So, when you add it to your
chart
Okay, you can see Let me get the cross
hairs up there.
Yeah, the top corner
top
uh left hand corner, you can see right?
This is just momentum strength point of
control level one level two. Okay?
For This one is this ultra bonds. Again,
you know, this is today. Obviously, we
had that big drop. This is yesterday
going up into the number then after the
number. Um
But, you can see it plots here. So, just
really quick I uh to address
a question that Michael had, can you
have
more than one instance running? Well,
yeah, you can. So, for example, if you
want to
Okay.
Um
We'll just throw another one up here
really quick. Uh
something that would be for maybe a a
reversal. Okay, so we'll just do swing
filter five and just really quick, we'll
just make it um
a bullish or bearish ratio. But if
you're going to add more than one
instance of it, you're probably going to
want to change the plot signals, okay?
Cuz the defaults are blue and red, blue
for bullish, red for um bearish. So, you
know, I'll just make it green.
And you know, that's not a conflicting
color.
Magenta.
Red and magenta kind of look alike. Uh
it's always hard with
this, but I know.
Uh I'll just make it
Whoops, not orange.
Let's make it gold.
Let's see.
And of course, what happened there?
Try it again here.
Refresh my screen. And NinjaTrader does
this every once in a while.
Bear with me.
I know what's going on.
It's my license It's the license server
is down.
Got to love these uh
live webinars.
I'm sure I'm connected to the internet
properly. Hang on here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Should be on now here. Let me just take
that off and just re-add it on. No, I I
I know what's going on. I know there's
an issue with the license server cuz I
can see it. I got a message came up on
my phone.
Okay,
let's add the new on here.
Going to make it
uh swing filter. Whoops.
And the other one is going to be ratios.
Come on.
Okay, I apologize for that. It's uh
Yeah, yes, I know it's the the server is
having some issues. But, I'll give you a
look at some question here.
Um
While waiting for that server reboot,
uh
Okay, so um
if you did automate, where would you put
stops and targets? Can they be automated
as well? Well, of course, you know, any
sort of automation tool, you can put
targets. I you know, I I I can't say oh,
it's got this amount because it depends
on you as a trader.
Right? What your take profit is, what
your target is. I mean, you can test it
to find what you're comfortable with.
But again, you know, every trader trades
different, Thomas. So, it's not like,
you know, Mike says it has to be in this
market, it has to be this amount of
ticks or for a a stop or
or take profit.
Um
will you ever design your Delta Scalper
Order Flow Toolbox or TradingView or any
other charting software for those who
don't use NinjaTrader?
You know, Noah,
it's a good question. Um
it is available well, not
Delta Scalper is
in the works for a web-based platform.
Uh GoCharting, we do have the Order
Flows Trader on there, but not the
Toolbox. The Toolbox is still
um
new.
So, we're going to see how it goes with
the uh Order Flows Trader before we add
the Toolbox on GoCharting.
Um
What happens basically, RJ? What happens
when I die? Um yeah, it's uh
We don't have the uh contingency plans
in for that yet. Like uh
Who's going to carry it on? But um you
know, my my programmer does
his stuff, I do my stuff, and
you know, we sort of work together on
it.
Does this indicator work with tick
replay? Yes, it does. Um
It
it does require tick replay cuz it is
reading the information
off of
off of the order flow.
Right? Which
you're going to need the tick replay
for. So, like, the information that you
see coming in off of the footprint
chart, right? It's being read in the
background
by
the Order Flows toolbox.
All right, but then it's combining
everything cuz like right now
So, like on the on this chart, okay? I
have my footprint,
right? You see here Order Flows Trader
as well as the toolbox on it. This one
is showing me
um exhaustion prints, momentum strength,
uh and Order Flow ratios, okay? So,
that's what you see plotted here, here,
here,
here, here.
Okay?
Bear with me, guys.
See here what's going on with this
thing. Let me try it on a new chart
here.
Open up.
Okay, uh
I will select balance. Give this one.
Uh Rashawn says uh which PC do I use uh
for trading?
here.
Show you.
Well, it's a Dell XPS you see there, but
um
You know,
I was going to show you the information
there, but um
This one is uh this one's an older one.
Um
I hate this Windows.
But it's
This is i7
um
it's 32 gig ram. Well, all I use this
one for is just trading and these
presentations and recordings.
I don't do anything else with it.
Oh, brother. I
Anyway, I've sent a message out to my
programmer to check the license server
on why it's not
What's going on? You know, the the host
of the license servers
Sometimes they do their updates and it
it skips a beat on
on our stuff. But um anyway, let me get
back to the presentation here.
I don't want to bite and end up cutting
it short. Um
Yeah, I my my whole goal was to show you
guys a bunch of charts and show you sort
of the
the
capabilities of it and uh
I apologize for this.
Let me see here if I
Um
let's just change this one here cuz this
one's exhaustion prints, right? With
ratios.
Okay, so here okay, now it's we're back
here. It's what I hate sometimes about
these things like the license servers is
they have hiccups. So, you see here now
I've changed this to momentum strength
and just the ratios, right? It's sitting
on the footprint chart. So, if you were
to
add another instance of this, getting
back to Michael's question,
say I want to
now use something with a swing filter,
I'm trying to think what would be a good
one to use here cuz I already got
exhaustion.
Now, I've got the
I've got ratios there. So, you know,
I'll make this uh
swing filter
with exhaustion prints, right? So, I'm
going to look for reversals, but I'm not
going to just limit it to
a ratio of a certain amount
of nine. You know, I'll make it 25 just
so it's a little bit easier. But if
you're going to use something that's
opposite, say a reversal,
uh you know, for bullish I'll do green.
For bearish, I'll do that
gold
gold color.
So, let's see
if anything comes up. So, you can see
here, right? There's the gold, there's
the gold.
I mean, bonds not necessarily a good uh
example, but you know, here's the gold.
This one's got both here, that's why
it's sort of this orange color.
Um you know, maybe if I did a different
markets
than bonds,
you could probably see it a little bit
better. So, try try euro currency.
Okay, so
here's the nice reversal off that low.
Right, but here's the momentum trade.
Okay, so
you know, right there there's the
bearish one. Now, the thing to keep in
mind, so let's just sort of jump into it
a little bit, is there is
the trade entry signal, okay, which I
have disabled for now.
Trade entry signal
means that okay, so it's on the momentum
it's turned off, but it's on for this
one I just added cuz by default it's
enabled.
Trade entry signal means the market has
to move two ticks, well, it has to move
certain amount of ticks over certain
amount of time. One, two ticks over
the next two bars. So, that's why
there's no signal given here because
this next bar it didn't move it only
moved one tick over the next two bars,
one tick lower than that low. Um that's
basically the the trade entry signal.
All right, so let's just close this one
chart down. Close this down. Let's just
see.
Go in here and
you know, there's question about NQ,
okay?
And
let's keep it as a
candlestick chart instead of footprint
chart. Um
but he did ask about 5 minutes.
Okay, so this is a 5-minute NQ chart,
okay?
And we got nice move going there, okay?
So,
you know,
NQ is a market that is volatile, right?
It moves around a lot.
You know, obviously, you know, on a day
like today where we got numbers and and
even yesterday you get a lot of
movement. Uh so
Let's add the toolbox here. Okay, so you
see it's down here, right? Toolbox. And
you know, just sort of keep it simple.
Now again, you know, it's a big runner
day, so
you know,
all you want to do is just buy and go
long. Um but always keep it simple since
you're asking about
momentum. Um again, this is a 5-minute
chart, it's not a 1-minute chart. Maybe
I should I should go down to a 1-minute.
But we'll we'll do this with open point
of control, which is kind of a a
momentum
signal. Okay.
So
here.
All right, we're going down, you know,
down down down. I don't have the
momentum turned on yet. But, you know,
obviously today's you know
a big runner day. You know, sometimes I
I see people like, "Oh, yeah, this this
was so easy." because it was a one-way
market. I like to also look at days
where you know, it's a bit back and
forth. You can see down, coming down,
going back up, right? Going back down.
Um
open point of control is not something
you're going to see necessarily as a
reversal sign. But if you wanted to
look at a tool that's, you know, can be
both a reversal
as well as momentum,
um let's just take a look at
Let's take a look at ratios. Just keep
it simple. Ratios, most of you guys are
familiar with
order flow ratios.
Okay, which is this, you know, ratio
balance high, ratio balance low. So if
it's above 30, it's price exhaustion.
Below uh 0.69, that's price defense.
Okay, but I'm not In this case, I'm not
looking at it in terms of
um uh coming in at highs or lows. What I
want to do is I'm going to
filter it
to come in at momentum.
Okay?
So, here we got ratios and momentum. So,
you know, on the way down, on the way
back up. Now, thing is on on longer-term
charts,
right? I
talk about the uh trade entry signal,
right? Where a market has to move a
certain amount.
Here. Where is it? Trade entry You know,
two ticks over two bars, okay? If I'm on
a longer-term chart like 5 minutes, I I
don't
I don't use that. I use it more for
minute-based charts
or faster-moving charts.
Um so, for example, if I was on a
1-minute chart,
okay? So, this is 1 minute and this one
we got uh ratio with momentum strength,
okay?
So, obviously the momentum
Oh. Bullish the entire day. Um you know,
you can't you can't fight that momentum.
Here it is during the night.
Again, this is just that one signal of
uh the bearish ratio. You know, when you
start adding in
um you know, something else like, for
example,
Mm.
I don't know.
Price action divergence.
Okay, again, I I don't know how it's
going to look on here.
Okay, so,
bearish bearish.
Some bullish ones and it holds bullish
here.
Yeah, that's a little bullish one there.
Bearish.
Here.
Start catching that move up this
morning.
I think obviously join
the session anything anything
any bullish sign is going to be well
rewarded. Um
there was question about eight range ES.
Let's call it ES
and eight range.
Okay.
So, again, this is just using the same
ones. I don't know what it's going to
look like with the eight range
um
ratios and price action divergence. You
know, there's a signal there.
It's one here, one there.
It's one there.
Yeah, this is yesterday here.
Um
and again, you know, what you can do
also, right? Like I said with the
multi time frame is so I'm on an eight
range chart, but it if say I was on an
eight range chart and I want to look at
the signals that are generated from
you know, a two-minute chart.
Again, I'm just going off top of my head
here.
Just to show you the the capability.
Okay, so you see it's calculating.
So, what what it's doing is
it's looking at different time frame and
putting it
on the chart that
you know, that that you trade. You know,
why would you want to do it again? Like
I said, I'm just picking
a two a two-minute chart
to put on there to overlay. You know,
you can do you know, if you want to do a
five minutes. Again, you know, say you
wanted to do
So, this is a range based chart, right?
If I wanted to do say a 5-minute show me
um
let me take off
that.
That's
That's say say I just wanted to show me
where
you know, there was thin prints of three
or less
that held on on the 5-minute chart. And
what I'll do is I just draw it out until
tested just so I could get a more of a
visual reference.
And again, you know, I notice I have
trade entry signal turned on, but I'll
disable that.
And I don't know how many
thin prints on 5-minute chart there are.
I'm just using three, but uh we'll see.
So, here.
Okay. So, not bad.
Okay. Obviously, during the night
session
things are a lot slower, but um
you know, this is not that bad.
That's with the
trade entry signal, I believe, turned
on. Now, you'll notice, right? Like
here's the zone up here, but the signal
comes in down here is because you know,
it's on a it's using the 5-minute
information. So, actually, the signal
doesn't come in till down here because
it's using it's looking at a it's
analyzing it on a 5-minute basis. That's
why the signal this is like sort of
where
it would have started, you know,
counting, but the signal is not
confirmed. Again, this is a range-based
chart, not time-based chart. If I was
looking at a time-based chart, this
would be all probably one bar.
Okay? That's why this signal is coming
in here versus down here is because it's
on a longer
time frame analysis, okay?
Um
You know, and again, you know, let's
just uh
go through some charts. So, that's an
eight range chart. Again, you know, if I
was on minute base chart
again, what do I got? I just got thin
prints on here
on a five minute basis.
But, say I want to change that to
you know, something
something else, you know. You know,
sometimes an easy way when you just
start playing around with this a lot you
get a little bit mixed up in here cuz
there's a lot of choices in here that
you could add. Uh simple thing that I do
is I just remove it, add it again, and
start from scratch. I mean, again, you
know, you could go through dig through
all the ones and make sure you enable um
disable everything.
But, um
some That's why, you know, it's nice
that everything's written up there at
the top corner so you could see what you
have. So,
this is E-minis one minute.
You know, again, you could
if you've looked at order flow long
enough, there's probably certain things
that you know and like to use.
So, you just go in and and add them,
right? Inverse volume imbalance. Um
momentum.
Okay.
What else? Well, add a thin print again.
Uh
we'll make it one though. I'll make it
like five.
And
volume imbalance. But, instead of three
this is for this is multiple imbalances,
not stacked imbalance, right? Volume
imbalance.
But, let's enable multiple imbalances.
Then, how many multiple imbalances in a
bar? Call it two.
Okay.
Just, you know, two imbalances, not
stacked on necessarily. They can be
stacked on each other, but even if
they're spread out a little bit.
Okay, so again, what do I got here? I've
got inverse volume imbalance.
Momentum strength thin prints volume
imbalance, okay?
Nothing going on there.
Yeah, sometimes you'll you'll get like
no signal.
You'll see like, you know,
nothing come up, okay? And it could be
Oh,
you know, maybe you might have something
enabled that you didn't know. That's why
I said I said sometimes it's a little
bit easier
to start from scratch, right? Where
This is
I guess what I'm trying to say is
sometimes, you know, people say they've
got all these tools, right? And they
want to say, "I want to add this, this,
this, this and everything all at once."
Well, you got to understand this is a
toolbox, right? So, you're taking
different pieces and adding them
together. So, if you were to add, you
know, all these things, right? For sure,
I'm not going to get anything.
Right? Cuz there's just too much going
on. It would have to be like in this
case,
you know, who knows? Maybe there might
be a signal. But, um
you know, yeah, I'm looking for volume
imbalance with a thin print, with
momentum strength, with volume inverse
volume imbalance, with a delta tail,
um
with a buying and selling tail, with a
delta divergence, with an aligned point
of control, with accumulation
distribution, right? You're just not
going to necessarily get all that
you know, all at once, right? And and
that's just how it is.
Um cuz
uh
combining too much
How How do What's a good way to describe
it? You know, when you add too many
things all at once, you're you're really
narrowing it down as to what you can
what you can find. So, for example here,
right? This is just simple momentum
strength
and prominent point of control level
one, level two, okay? And again, you
know, we had that big down day, nothing
else is going on right now, but you can
see like yesterday
Oops.
Here, right? Yesterday, nice move up,
nice move down. It's not about adding
every single thing, you know, on there
all at once, right? It's about adding
things that help make sense. You know,
maybe
um
I don't know what I got. Prominent point
of controls. Maybe I I want to
you know, see these in
not necessarily, you know, not
you know, like like Well, this one has
also got the momentum strength turned
on. Yeah, if I want to see it with uh
Well, you see, again, you're not going
to have an open point of control with a
prominent point of control. Those would
work against each other. But, let me
just find something uh uh uh
maybe with a volume decline.
Okay, so you see not, you know, just the
one there. By adding more,
sometimes you you just
the combination of that actually
happening becomes less. You know, it's
one thing to look at um you know, a
footprint and
see that, oh, you know what? I've got
this, this, this, and this in this one
bar, you know, that's automatic. Why?
Well, yeah, but the uh uh
chance of that happening could be um
quite slim, you know, so
for example, if
you know, again, but that's a that's a
5-minute chart, right? If I were to go
down to
I don't know what it is. I don't know um
a 1-minute chart, maybe I'll get
different signals, okay? Cuz it's a
little bit faster, so I can get some um
signals like you're seeing here today on
this
This is Euro currency.
You know, yesterday
and then yesterday there was no signals
in that.
Um
that's just because I've added an extra
layer, an extra filter
that
it should probably just not doesn't
occur that much. You know, you probably
don't get volume decline very often with
a prominent point of control.
Okay? Maybe, you know, then you can
start looking at things like um you
know, maybe some delta clues.
You know, call it uh
Well, we'll we'll use the extreme delta
threshold, but we'll just make we'll
lower the threshold down to 80. Okay?
Okay, so you see there's some signals
here, nice move here. You know, people
say, "Well, this one was failure." Well,
yeah, okay, it got stopped out. Um
you know, with some decent moves there.
I don't know about today.
You know, I'm not going to say, "Yeah,
you could have done that." But um
you know, you're you're getting some
decent movement. So, you know, it's
about finding the combination that works
for you, that has enough
uh
opportunities for you in a trading day.
Okay, so
you know, for example, if
you know, I know a lot of traders who
are on I'm on the 1-minute chart, okay?
Let me just uh
clean this stuff up here. So, we'll take
off the extreme delta, take off
everything, momentum strength,
prominent point of controls.
Okay?
Trade entry.
Okay, and
basic one.
Stacked imbalances. When I build stuff
out, right? I like to start at a basic
premise, okay? Stacked imbalance.
Okay.
Okay. The stacked imbalance here,
stacked bind imbalance here, stacked
bind imbalance here, stacked bind
imbalance here. Actually, what I'm going
to do is
I will disable the trade entry signal
for now.
So, it's going to show me right on the
bar that has a stacked bind imbalance
here, here, here, here, okay?
Then, that's where I go, right? I start
with one, then I start adding the pieces
that I think
will have a good effect on the market,
okay? So, for example, right? If I'm
looking at this market and I see, well,
let me close this down. You know, I had
a stacked bind imbalance here that kind
of went nowhere.
I had one here that, again, kind of went
nowhere.
This one, okay. This one for sure, this
one for sure.
Well, what's the difference? You know,
this one's coming in and out of low.
This one's coming in, you know, a bar
off the low. This one's
You know, I I I I would not call this a
swing low. You know, this one's coming
in a bit of momentum, the market's
moving. So,
you know, stacked imbalances where the
market's moving is
probably something I want to start
focusing on, okay? So, then, you know,
that's how you start adding in the
layers, like the pieces that will help
you
um
determine which way the market's going.
So, you can just buy throw in first
filter. Let me just put this over here
of
momentum.
Okay? So, it took out those two bad
trades there.
Okay? Now, it leaves me with these two,
you know? Is this good enough to be a
trading setup? You know,
again,
I'm not talking about that one, but uh
you know, you just then you start doing
the eye test. You know what? Hey, this
is not too bad. Stacked momentum or
sorry, stacked imbalance with momentum.
Okay?
Simple, all right? That's just a basic
one of order flow. But you know, again,
I I I'd like to have caught this move.
You know, maybe there's something in the
order flow that took place there. You
know, I can I can see, you know, what
happened in that move.
You know, that's that's order flow
related that maybe I could build
something around.
And then I can look at, okay, well, at
the extreme delta threshold, I left the
momentum on.
All right, so extreme delta threshold.
Yeah, I caught a a lot of that move.
Again, it's set to 80,
which is quite liberal.
Um
And here, you know, maybe with the
extreme delta
volume threshold, I could add that on
there.
Okay?
A little bit better. It's
removed a couple of those
couple of those signals. Um
you know, then maybe you want to sort of
give it a boost and say, you know, on
one that that have open point of
controls.
Okay?
So
Okay, now that you have your your idea,
then you you can walk it forward. Look,
how is it doing? Now I like always check
how it does overnight as well as during
the day.
You know.
So not too bad. So again, there there's
a lot I can go through all sorts of
examples here, but you I don't want to
keep you on all all morning.
Um
you know, because it's
it just really is it's a great tool,
especially if, you know, you like
I know there's a lot of you guys out
there. I'm I'm a bit like this. I'm a
bit of a what you call a tinkerer.
You know, we like to tinker around with
the the and see, see what we can squeeze
out of the market. Um
you can't see it here on my desk, but,
you know, I I have I've got
combinations that I like and, you know,
it's it's something that I think
you know, many traders will will get a
lot of value out of
because, you know, at the end of the
day, it's about finding what works for
you.
So, again, you know, if you're
interested, I think it's it's a great
tool for everyone. It's the uh
I'm going to put it in the chat here,
but what you got to do is you got to go
to this uh orderflows toolbox at
orderflows.com/toolbox.
Let's put it in the chat.
orderflows.com/
toolbox, okay?
You know, this is the page here.
Click on it. It's it's in the chat
there.
And
again, you know,
I I wanted to put all sorts of charts on
here, but I I could make a whole page
full of these things. We do have a
special for the
this launch for this webinar. Um regular
price is going to be $14.99. I'll be
honest, you know, my programmer was
against me releasing this
um
for our own various reasons because, you
know, it's a tool that we use
you know, for our own trading as well as
our own testing and stuff.
But, uh finally finagled him to
to do it. So, I think that's why um
you know, sort of took a while to get
this released.
But, normal price is going to be $14.99.
You can get it now for $9.99. That's 500
bucks off. You know, people are going to
say that's a lot of money. It's not
really, you know, indicators go from
anywhere between 300 to $500 for one
single indicator. This is like a whole
You saw it's a whole toolbox, right? You
got all those You've got all the all of
these um
tools and you can combine them however
you want, right? So, really the only
thing that's holding you back is your
own,
uh, thought process on, you know, what I
like to look at prominent point of
controls that occur with, uh, order flow
ratios. Okay? Um, things like that. And
just make it, you know, much more
streamlined, right? So, yeah, you could
either pay through Stripe or through
PayPal right there.
And
you know, like, I you know, for order
flows
trader,
right? We do weekly, um,
calls.
And you know, if you get this software,
the order flows toolbox, you're going to
be invited to those calls cuz again,
it's
it's all about sharing the information,
all right? I mean, you know, people say,
"Well, you you you you get all that for
free on YouTube." You you you can't. You
know, what I talk about on, um, on these
calls is is
you know, my own analysis stuff. And
sometimes other things that people share
with me that they're fine with me
sharing with the group. And
not only that, but for the toolbox,
I'm going to do bi-weekly sessions as
well, just specific to the toolbox, not
for anybody else.
And so, not for the, uh, order flows
trader because, you know, the toolbox is
a specialized tool in the sense that
you know,
we'll be sharing so I'll say, "Hey, you
know what? On gold on a 1-minute chart,
you know, you could use Momo momentum,
thin prints, volume imbalance, and, um,
inverse imbalance."
And
it is going to just help you get further
and further ahead. Now, the first
meeting for that's probably not going to
start till, um,
September, okay? Like the first week of
September after Labor Day. But we're
going to be doing them bi-weekly, okay?
And the difference between that call and
and the call for order flows trader,
again, is this one is specific to the
order flows toolbox. You'll also be
invited to the weekly order flows trader
calls where we talk about the footprint
and you know, things that we're looking
for in the footprint, but this one is
specific to the toolbox, right? Cuz I
think it's
I think it's a great tool. You know,
sometimes people
are like, oh, I can't share with what I
know with the market, you know, because
it's like they'll
come up to me, Mike, I got I found it. I
discovered the holy grail.
And
you know, I'm a big believer in okay,
you know, you you sit in your office
home office,
so to speak,
like me. I
sit in a home office and
if I say I discover some so for like
order flows pull up an order flow chart
here really quick.
Um
Right, if I'm looking at
if I'm looking at the footprint, right?
And
I I see something occurring, you know,
at a low over and over and over and
over. Well, why is that? Because I'm
looking at the order flow. What it is
it's the buying and selling of the
participants that are that are trading
whereas, you know, sometimes people will
be like, oh, Mike, I got this system is
based off of these different indicators,
moving averages, etc.
And then like 6 months later like and
like how's it doing? Well, you know,
it's it's not working anymore cuz it was
curve fitted. Whereas with order flow,
order flow is
all the traders what they're doing in
the market.
And that's behavior as opposed to sort
of price action. That's why, you know,
if if you're following order flow,
you're really following what
the big traders are doing cuz at the end
of day it's the big traders that are
moving the market. Okay? Whereas if
you're just watching price, you know,
if you watch price long enough
and you watch order flow long enough,
you know, price can move on very little
flow, so to speak. You know, if you look
at the NASDAQ,
you know, it can jump around without
trading any price for, you know, three,
four ticks sometimes.
So,
that's why with orderflow,
I think it's in everybody's best
interest to share,
you know, what's working because the
more people behind it,
sort of the better it works. You know, I
I I hate to call it a self-fulfilling
prophecy, but if the more people are
seeing what you're seeing and and are
going in on it,
or for whatever reason, again, I could
be looking at this and say, "Oh, you
know, I think this market is going up
because thin print, thin print over two
consecutive bars or something like
that." Okay, and you see the market went
up, but I know that that is because
of the way the market is trading in in
the two-way auction, right? With the
thin print is meaning there's there's
just not enough um two-way flow, right?
That it's dominating one way or the
other, and I know that if the market is
dominated by buyers, aggressive buyers,
it's going to go up.
Okay? But if you're just looking at bars
by themselves, you don't understand the
underlying
aspect of the mechanics that's taking
place in the markets.
Okay?
Um so, that's why, you know, I I
am planning to do the weekly Oh, that's
right, this one's going to be bi-weekly
for now,
um which may move up to weekly as as
more and more traders get involved
with the toolbox. Because again, you
know, it's not everybody trades
ES on a 1-minute chart. You know, people
trade ES on an 8-minute chart Oh, sorry,
8-range chart. Some people trade on a
30-second chart. Some people trade, you
know, even shorter than that, 30
seconds. Some people trade a 12-range
chart. Some people trade a 3-minute.
There's so many different
And that's just one market, all There's
just there's so many different markets
out there. There's you know, there's
about 40 that's that's worth trading. Um
that you know, for some people they may
not realize that hey, you know what?
Maybe in you know, in another market it
I I should probably focus on that as
opposed to this market that I'm trading,
you know. So, for example, um
you know, people laugh at me.
You know, I talk about the grains,
but you know, the grains do offer great
trading opportunities, okay? So, let's
just go here. That's the footprint,
right? And honestly, for a lot of
traders, they don't want to look at a
footprint like this, cuz it's like uh
it's so ugly, you know? Then
this is a 5-minute chart.
Here we are on a 1-minute chart.
Okay? You see there's decent signals
here during the day. Day starts uh right
here, 8:30.
Okay? But again, you know, a move like
this, 306
80 all the way up to 309 80. That's a
$300 move right there.
Okay? So, for some traders, you know,
that might be a better market. Maybe
they're going to look at again again,
ultra bonds that I tried showing
earlier.
Um
you know, maybe they they're
more
friend you know, they're more willing to
trade ultra bonds, which move a lot
more, okay? This move here from
you know, whatever this is, you know,
uh down to 25.
You know, that's
12 points, 12 ticks.
Um you know, a little scalp here, a
little scalp here. So, again, you know,
there's so many different markets that
it's it's not like it's going to be
saturated and uh I don't think so, you
know, the markets are so robust that
you know, us as retail traders,
we're nothing to the markets. You know,
we're just
we're we're ants, you know, we just get
our our
two, three, four, or lots get in the way
of what the big traders are doing,
actually.
Um so, anyway, I'm going to take a look
at some questions here.
Uh
Looks like a very complex system, too
many choices. Okay, fine. You know, if
it's not for you, it's not for you.
Um simple, you know, I I can't convince
you, Chris, if if you think it's too
complex. Honestly, I I think it's very
simple to use.
Um if I purchase order flow for NT, can
I use it on GoCharting, too? No,
uh William, it's it's two different
platforms. And
it's just not the same. But, the
difference with GoCharting is GoCharting
is a monthly subscription.
And
NinjaTrader's is not. Now,
GoCharting, I'm going to be
doing some announcements on that
next week, cuz we're we're just really
sort of in the beta stages of
the release for GoCharting. But,
it's just the footprint right now, but
Delta Scalper will be getting on there
uh later. Will the toolbox work with the
Ninja Cator's order flow
that you designed?
Um I didn't design the Ninja Cator
order flow, but
I think I have it on here, actually. Let
me uh
open up a new chart.
Cuz the the important thing is you need
tick replay, okay?
I think
like the IES, this is
Well, first I'll
use the the native uh
Where is it here?
Uh
I don't even know what to call it on
here. Um
Oh, it's the volumetric chart.
This is the NinjaTrader
one, but let me just uh
Okay, so this is the Ninja
Ninja Trader one,
which
kind of basic.
Um
So you have the toolbox on there.
And let's keep it simple.
We'll just look for exhaustion prints.
If there are any.
Uh
Okay.
Yeah, so again it's just showing you
it's hard to see cuz it's black, but
you can sort of see it coming in here.
Now
Ninja, this is the So this is the Ninja
Trader one.
Okay, and I I know they're
they use a slightly different
calculation than we use. We use
um actual bid ask data. They use up and
down tick. But I think your question
also was the NinjaCators one, so
let me uh
put on the NinjaCator one. So I think
the
Well, let me just go back to a bar chart
here.
Cuz the NinjaCators one
footprint
Uh
okay.
I I I hate this I hate it red screen. I
hate it black screen. Um
Well, let me just change this to a white
candlestick. Okay.
It's better on my eyes.
I got to add the indicator back on, but
uh toolbox.
Okay, and let's do exhaustion prints.
I yes.
What's there? It's been called
order flow sequence tracker.
So we lost.
I I forgot if there's requires tick
replay or not.
It still says calculating there.
No.
You know what? Cuz I got my template on
there.
I would have to go back to an old
templates, not this templates. So for
example, if I were to load
ES
on, okay, then I add there's
Again, I'm only showing this cuz there's
this question about it.
So we are done. I don't know why the
footprints are not showing up here
anymore.
Uh
Oh, that's the sequence tracker. What's
this called? Is it really called that?
Uh
We want volume at price.
This will pro order flow pro.
Hm.
Try this one.
I don't know why the indicators
order flow chart is not showing up here.
Hm.
So, okay. I'm not sure why it's not
showing up. Okay, it's got to have tick
replay off. So, no, that's why it's not
showing up. Cuz I got to have tick
replay on for the toolbox.
Okay.
Um
Simon asked, "So, I see some new tools
in this which are not in the 32 Order
Flow Trader?"
The Let's go back to the list here.
Order Flow
Simon, you should be on Order Flow
Trader 7, okay?
Um
And
all these are in Order Flow Trader 7.
The one that's not
I think
Well,
I know the multi-time frame one is not.
And
you know, the multi-time frame one
we we can't do that on a footprint
chart. Well, we could, but it's going to
it's
going to be a lot of extra ex-
extra
um computing. It's just not It's not
It's not worth it. It's better to put it
on the the toolbox than put it on
the actual footprint chart.
Is the um
momentum is not on here as well. So,
we have swing filter, we don't have
momentum. So, this one here, the from
time frame, which is, you know, allow
you to look at, you know, tick, volume,
range, second, minute chart um of
different values,
and put it on your existing chart. That
is not part of Order Flow Trader.
Um the footprint and
the momentum strength is not yet.
One says, uh,
had to go. Um,
just need to receive the internals
control.
Okay, yeah, I'll look for your email
about it.
Assume you can combine or Aaron asks to
you can combine pulse
and or turn with toolbox.
Um, yeah, that's a good question. So,
for example,
if you have
a tool like the
pulse
And yeah, I'll change these to
green
and let's make it deep
pink.
Instead of gold, I didn't like the gold.
Um,
Okay, what settings do I got here? Do do
do do strength zero. Let's make it
strength one.
And
delta
I'll take off long bars. Okay.
Uh,
I should pulse probably not.
What do I get on there? Pulse, let me
try a different market here.
Okay, so like here's pulse signals here
here.
The one right here, the green. The
magenta.
So, yeah, you can use it in combination,
but you what you can't do
is you can't combine the pulse with the
toolbox, but you can use them both on
the same chart.
Um
Aaron asks, "Jacob, I see your in your
question there
about the license.
I'll get to that after we're done here.
Why did you switch from range to minute
charts?"
Um
Years ago I used to use range charts.
Markets weren't as volatile as they are
now. Um that's why.
Um Jama asks, "On the period type,
what's the difference between chart and
minute selection?"
On the period type, okay, so chart
as opposed to any of these, chart being
at zero would be
the actual chart that's on your screen.
If you want, you know, a different
underlying
you know, let's like say
yeah, you want to see signals from a
30-second chart on your 1-minute, you
can you would do that. Or
say what do I got here?
Uh
single currency, so
you know, I don't know, 100 tick chart
on a euro currency, right?
So this is a 1-minute chart, but it's
going to show me the signals
but on my 1-minute chart based off of a
100 tick chart.
Mostly uh Reggie asks, "Are these tools
in the Order Flows Trader 7?" Yeah, they
are. Again, like I said, except for the
multi-time frame and momentum, but you
can't combine them the way that you're
doing it here, right? If you're looking
at footprint
then you have to make it you have to
say, "Okay, yeah, I see this, this, and
this."
You know, one, two, and three
four, five things happening in the bar
that would make you want to get long,
right? So, now
like here, I see, okay, I've got a
you know, bar that's got uh exhaustion
print, imbalance
reversal, couple of thin prints
and it's got
a delta
um threshold. So,
what I can do
is
take that off here.
And
you know, I wanted to highlight cuz you
know, I Oh, I know, I've seen this
happen so many times. You know, maybe
this is This is a good signal. So, what
I'll do is I'll change this to, you
know, keep it at nine.
And
um inverse
Well, it's got a delta threshold over
95%. It's got a imbalance reversal, and
it's got
you know, thin prints
two of them in here.
Okay?
Take this off now just to show you, make
sure everything else is
right.
Turn off the swing filter for now.
So, boom. I It's
showing me that instance right here
of everything I just combined on it.
Okay? I don't know if there's anything
else, but
this is it. This is the signal based off
of thin prints, imbalance reversal,
delta threshold
and
exhaustion print all wrapped up in one
bar giving you one signal.
Here, it says, "Will not work cuz you're
trying to line too many compliances at
the same time."
Um
I don't agree with that. I don't agree
with that. But, uh
simply because
one instance of order flow can happen.
All right, but what is
momentum, right?
Unless aggressive trading taking place.
Okay, so I know if I have a reversal
signal with momentum.
It's not like I'm adding too many. But
again, you know, like I said, if this is
just not something you believe in,
that's fine. You know, there's
that's what makes trading trading. Not
everybody agrees. If everybody agreed,
markets wouldn't move.
Basically, um it's just just like
uh
It's just like, you know, you go to
YouTube. Videos, uh order flow is crap,
doesn't work. Oh, Bookmap is crap, it
doesn't work. Um
you know, the dome, it doesn't work.
There's only price action. Yeah, I trade
this way. No, there's there's so many
different ways to trade.
You know, I know what works for me.
I know what works for other traders. And
you know, that's why we developed this
product because a lot of traders has
specifically asked for something like
this over the years.
And
it was just now we we've
finally been able to
um put enough tools into it that makes
it viable as well as, you know,
something that
is
is useful to other traders.
Uh do you need the order flow software
for this toolbox work? No, you don't.
That's the beauty of it. You don't need
the footprint chart.
It's like a foot We used to call this
the OFT, which is
the abbreviation for order flow trader,
FPL, footprintless chart.
Right? Cuz you see me showing it to you
on a chart with the footprint. But
really, the power is it's coming in off
of you know, regular charts just like
this. You can use it with your existing
chart. So, if you're like me and you got
43-in monitors, you got screen here,
screen here, screen here, screen here.
You can have a bunch of little charts
going on with the setups that you like
to use.
Uh
No, Reggie, it's not part of
it's not part of the Order Flow Trader
software. It's separate from that. This
is completely different software.
Huh.
Okay, Aaron, you got it. Thanks.
Um
Yeah, you know, Aaron, send me over, you
know, what markets you're interested in
um cuz yeah, I see you know
some basic setups for entry and
continuation and exits. Um
Yeah, because you know, I I'll I'll send
you some setups, but if it's not on a
market that you look at, it's not going
to be useful, but
send me over some, you know, a list of
things that you look at and time frame.
Uh
Can we use the footprint as well as the
candlestick chart? Yes, Carol, you can.
Um
Can be automated with markers?
Yes, should be able to. I I haven't done
cuz I had to upgrade I upgraded my PC
testing PC and so I had to get
all new
license from Pablo for markers, not
license, but he had to update my machine
ID, etc.
But I I want to make a video on that for
you guys
as well once I get that sorted out. Uh
what can help the tick charts be more
stable and have less lag?
Um
I'm not sure I understand you, Carol.
What can help the tick charts to be more
stable? I I I think tick charts are
generally pretty stable and
I again, it's it's
it's one of those things where
check your data connection.
Um
Do you have templates for the buyers of
the toolbox? Well, you know, we're going
to be doing we're going to be meeting
um
bi-weekly.
So, you know, we'll be sharing things
and again, you know,
Yolanda, if there's a market that you're
interested in
or that you trade
you know, send me over, you know, the
the market, the time frame, etc. and and
you know, I can take a look cuz you
know, it's one thing for me to put out a
bunch of templates, but it's kind of
pointless if
you know, like me to put out a
an ultra bond template for you if you
don't trade ultra bonds, right? If you
trade
um British pound
you know, if you tell me, "Yeah, I trade
British pound and on a 1-minute chart,
what what
what's a good template to use?" Then
it's a lot easier, okay?
Uh
Thomas says, "Is
No, it's it's the same computing power
as the regular footprint?" I I haven't
noticed anything different. Again, I I
have no issues running it. You saw me
earlier, I had issue with the license
server. It was it was just it was just
down for a couple minutes, which
not the greatest example during a live
webinar. Um
but uh
Yeah. What time frames would be the best
to use the toolbox? How can I use it
with
10-minute, 15-minute, 1-hour? Well,
although I don't really go out to 1-hour
in order flow
but there are certain things that I like
to look at in order flow
on
you know, 10-minute, 15-minute charts.
So
I'll just
change this to
you know, minutes
um
just really quick.
Like I keep it simple.
On longer time frames,
I really keep it simple. I use
I like I've always liked exhaustion
prints.
Sorry. Whoops. This is exhaustion print
on
longer time frames. So, what do I What
do I put in here? 15 minutes?
Cuz I got the pulse on here.
Get that off.
Okay.
Yeah, nothing new. You saw that we had
that big drop today, but you know,
sometimes when I I see them coming in at
like a swing high like this, it's very
powerful signal for me.
You know, there's a little swing high.
Um but again, there's so many different
ways you can use it. How do I bring up
the order flow chart on NinjaTrader?
Um you'd have to go to the data series.
If you have the paid version of
NinjaTrader,
you'd go and change the chart type to
volumetric.
Okay.
But I'm not going to do that now. Let's
keep it on my normal
minute chart.
So, anyway, guys, I won't keep you guys
on any longer. I think I've gone through
all the questions. Um again, you know,
thanks for
coming out here. You know, for those of
you guys that bought it, I'm going to
get you guys sorted out uh you know,
straight away right after this call.
And again, you know, I think it's a
great tool for everybody to use. Again,
is it for everybody? No. You know, you
have to believe in in order flow and
understand what you're looking at. You
know, I mean, there's people that are
despise order flow. Fine. You know,
that's not to say order flow is useless.
I mean those guys oh your price action
is the only way. Yeah, okay, fine. If
that works for you, you know, order flow
works for
a lot of traders, a lot of professional
traders.
So
Again, thanks for coming out here today
and I look forward to working with you
guys and seeing you on on our
in our bi-weekly meetings and and
sharing
you know, things that we've learned and
you know, what what we find is is
working good. And again, you know, the
beauty of for those of you that have had
my products, you know, that we're always
updating it, right? We're on order flows
trader version seven already.
Okay, and every time we come up with a
new release there's always new tools in
there and the same thing is going to be
with the toolbox, right? Whatever is
going into the order flows trader is
going to go into the toolbox and vice
versa. So maybe there's a way that you
like to analyze order flow, let me know,
you know, is that something we could add
to the toolbox?
We'll do it.
All right, everyone. Have a great rest
of your day and rest of your week and
again, thanks for coming out and I'll
get you guys sorted out. Bye-bye.